yo creo que las consecuencias van a ser
graves y espero que así lo sean
precisamente en esa dirección estoy
trabajando aquí en washington porque las
condiciones felizmente han cambiado el
bus que le hoy día gobierna una tiranía
tiene una total concentración de poder
ya lo que existe en el salvador es
lastimosamente apenas una fachada
democrática acaba de salir un
pronunciamiento hace menos de una hora
de los dos senadores de los más
importantes e influyentes de los estados
unidos uno dirige el comité de asuntos
exteriores y otro dirige el comité de
apropiación de apropiaciones donde se
manejan los fondos de eeuu en esta
declaración de estos dos senadores hacen
un llamado a la administración bailén es
decir al gobierno el presidente va a ir
en qué condiciones sus relaciones
incluso incluso económicas a través del
fondo monetario internacional sus
condiciones las relaciones en el caso
del salvador a la restitución de la
independencia judicial y la separación
de poderes principios básicos un sistema
democrático
señor vivanco qué es lo que preocupa
puntualmente a la comunidad
internacional la concentración de poder
el hecho de que hoy día un gobierno que
ganó las elecciones crea que puede
gobernar como un déspota acumulando todo
el poder en sus manos incluyendo a todo
el poder judicial ya los mecanismos de
control incluyendo el ministerio público
han destituido a las autoridades claves
y pareciera que la intención es seguir
adelante con el tribunal electoral y
otros mecanismos de fiscalización de lo
que es este el trabajo o la gestión
gubernamental uno de los problemas
fundamentales del salvador es la falta
de de rendición de cuentas es decir la
impunidad que existe frente al abuso de
poder y esa es una de las razones y
además de la corrupción que explican la
migración masiva de salvadoreños a los
eeuu a los eeuu les importa mucho hoy
día que el salvador respete las normas
democráticas y construye la
institucionalidad de control y que evite
el abuso de poder y lo que está
ocurriendo es
contra él